foreign
of mobile devices robots and social
media content creation is the most
effective inbound marketing strategy
nearly 40 percent of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81 percent say
their company views content as a
business strategy
original and high quality content can
help your company stand out and attract
your customers and help your business
grow on that note welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we are here
with a fantastic video on chat GPT for
Content creation which will help you
create some compelling content on your
desired topics but before we begin are
you aiming to get certified as a digital
marketer and want to build your career
in digital marketing well in that case
you can check the professional digital
marketing course by simply learn which
will open the doors for the best career
opportunities to find the details of the
professional digital marketing course
check the link in the description box
below it could be an ideal solution to
help your build career in the right
direction and if you haven't subscribed
already please subscribe to our Channel
simply learn and hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us but before
we get started guys I have a question
for you is chargpt an application and is
it available on Android well let us know
the answer in the comments below so let
us understand what is chat GPT here now
go content creation can be of any type
such as blogs podcasts videos graphics
and so on but how do you create high
quality content with a few minutes you
not be worried when we have chat GPT now
even though there are numerous AI
writing tools for Content creation chat
GPT stands out from the crowd due to its
faster response rate ease of use
increased productivity support for
multiple languages and other benefits
now let's try to understand what exactly
chat Jupiter is and how to create
content from it
now generally charge GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally
chat GPT is capable of systematically
resolving all bugs while providing
detailed explanation for each step it
takes so in simple words charge GPT is a
tool that creates content for any query
chart GPT stands out among all the other
achievements of open AI
so let us now move ahead and understand
how does chat GPT work now chart GPT
uses deep learning techniques to
generate human-like text which is based
on a machine learning model derived from
the large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chart GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers shared their views on an
individual subject now there are a
variety of categories for writing a Blog
so let's pick one for charge epd here
so as you can see we have navigated into
charge APD and let us now ask a simple
question about food blocking now lately
food blogs are the most popular blogs
that everyone wants to write about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to chat GPT and it will answer so I'm
just writing a question here saying how
to
start a
word
blogging career
so as you can see it is generating the
answer for us wait for it to end
well as you can see it is saying that
starting a food block can be a fun and
rewarding way to share your love or food
with others so it is showing us some
steps to get started in food blogging
career it is saying choose anishe choose
a name and domain choose a blogging
platform create your blog create high
quality content and so on so in this way
charging PT will automatically generate
the response for you based on the
questions that you are giving input to
it next we will see another question on
lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular uh entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in charge GPT as
well and see what it will show the
answer so let's uh give the question as
how to
start
lifestyle
blogging in India
so it is giving the answer for us guys
so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interests so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points whereas in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your Niche choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on so guys what are your
thoughts on how effective the chat GPT
is for Content creation do let me know
in the comments below please like this
video and share it with your friends for
more such videos visit the simply learn
YouTube channel for queries regarding
this topic mention them in the comment
box thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign